frage machen wir haben ja in den letzten
vier wochen also seit beginn der harten
maßnahmen und der kontakt beschränkungen
insgesamt sehr viel erreicht es ist
insbesondere gelungen die
infektionszahlen soweit unter kontrolle
zu bringen dass sie nicht mehr
exponentiell steigen und dass dies
gelungen ist dass der re
produktionsfaktor jetzt auch unter 1 ist
dass wir an etlichen tagen mehr genesene
haben als neue infizierte
das ist vorneweg den bürgerinnen und
bürgern zu verdanken die alle
einschränkungen bezug über großer
disziplin und insgesamt auch sehr viel
geduld getragen haben und auch heute
möchte ich dafür von ganzem herzen noch
einmal danke sagen es gibt also eine
wachsende zahl von genießen
beschränkungen aber wir dürfen keine
sekunde aus den augen verlieren dass wir
trotz allem immer noch ganz am anfang
der pandemie stehen dass wir am anfang
stehen und noch lange nicht über den
berg sind
und ich glaube das müssen wir uns gerade
zu beginn dieser woche in der er die
erste lockerungen in kraft treten wieder
und wieder klarmachen
natürlich fällt das schwer aber wenn wir
jetzt beschränkungen aufheben wenn wir
lockerungen machen
dann wissen wir eben nicht genau was die
folge davon ist und deshalb müssen wir
schrittweise langsam und vorsichtig
vorgehen
denn es wäre jammerschade wenn wir
sehenden auges in ein rückfall gen wenn
der sehenden auges die ersten erfolge
gefährden würden und deshalb dürfen wir
keine sekunde lang leichtfertig oder
leichtsinnig werden wir dürfen uns keine
sicher keine sekunde in sicherheit
wiegen ist ganz ganz wichtig dass wir
sozusagen wieder leichtsinnig sind noch
uns in sicherheit wiegen sondern wir
müssen wachsam und diszipliniert bleiben
und wenn ich von dir redet dann sind wir
das alle die bürgerinnen und bürger
dieses landes
und damit das auch ganz klar ist ich
weiß ja um die not vieler menschen
ich weiß um die not von eltern und
kindern um die not gerade auch von
alleinerziehenden
ich sehe die not so vieler in der
gastronomie bei den hotels und ich sehe
die nur zu vieler menschen die um die
zukunft ihres geschäfts ihres betriebs
ihres unternehmens bangen
auch die not vieler künstler die nicht
wissen wie es für sie weitergehen kann
ich sehe die erwartung der kirchen und
religionsgemeinschaften die den
gläubigen mehr als nur online
gottesdienste ermöglichen möchten und
die sehnsucht von gläubigen in den
gottesdiensten endlich wieder die
gemeinschaft mit anderen erleben zu
können
ich sehe natürlich das dringende
bedürfnis das freiheitsrecht der
versammlung und demonstrationen wieder
wahrnehmen zu können
und ich weiß auch um die not einsamer
menschen die ihre einsamkeit jetzt noch
viel viel stärker spielen als sonst und
das heißt ja auch diese pandemie
verlangt uns allen in diesem lande
neben einzelnen aber auch der
gemeinschaft ziemlich viel ab aber ich
bin zugleich davon überzeugt dass wir
all dieser not all den hoffnungen und
erwartungen wünschen und ansprüchen am
besten begegnen wenn wir gerade am
anfang dieser pandemie weiter auch die
kraft zu haben und strengen maßnahmen
aufbringen
ich will noch einmal daran erinnern dass
wir am letzten mittwoch gemeinsam in den
ministerpräsidenten ja beschlossen haben
dass bis mindestens dritter mai die
regeln weiter gelten 15 meter abstand im
freien aufenthalt zu hause nur im
eigenen haus stand im freien auch nur
mit dem eigenen hausstand oder aber mit
einer person die nicht zu diesem haus
stand gehört keine touristischen reisen
keine reisen sozusagen in die ferne und
meine sorge um eine mahnung so zu sagen
dass wir am anfang dieser epidemie jetzt
ganz sorgsam sind dass wir konzentriert
bleiben
die habe ich auch in allen gesprächen
und mache ich in allen gesprächen mit
den ministerpräsidenten der bundesländer
deutlich damit der spielraum den wir uns
gegeben haben und dieser spielraum wird
ja umgesetzt
im wesentlichen von den bundesländern
durch die allgemeinverfügung durch die
zuständigkeit im infektionsschutzgesetz
also dass dieser spielraum möglichst eng
ausgenutzt wird und nicht möglichst weit
denn ich glaube dass wir ansonsten
gefahr laufen könnten dass wir die
lockerungen nicht genau übersehen die
sich situationen die wir jetzt jeden tag
haben sie ist eben trügerisch denn das
was wir heute begonnen haben die öffnung
der läden auf die wir uns auch gemeinsam
geeinigt haben was das bedeutet
bezüglich der infektionszahlen das sehen
wir in 14 tagen
und nicht vorher und das ist das was die
sache so schwierig macht
und ich glaube uns eint alle bund und
länder ministerpräsidenten bürgerinnen
und bürger und mich und die
bundesregierung dass es keinen erneuten
allgemeinen shutdown geben wird dass er
nicht wieder verhängen werden muss aber
das wäre natürlich die folge bei einem
erneuten exponentiellen wachstum der
infektionszahlen wäre unvermeidlich und
es würde dazu führen dass wir in
krankenhäusern doch in eine notsituation
kommen die wir bis jetzt nicht hatten
und genau das wollen wir vermeiden dass
wir so zu so dramatischen zuständen
kommen wie in anderen ländern
und weil wir natürlich auch gerade vor
erkrankte menschen ältere menschen nicht
in gefahr bringen wollen wir wollen sie
aber auch nicht monatelang isolieren
man könnte auch wegsperren sagen das
entspreche in keiner weise unserem
menschenbild und ich glaube ganz fest
dass sozusagen die verhinderung eines
rückschritts dass wir wieder
zurückkehren müssen zu härteren
maßnahmen nicht nur im interesse der
bekämpfung der pandemie ist sondern auch
im interesse der entwicklung unserer
wirtschaft und des gesellschaftlichen
lebens und deshalb werde ich nicht
nachlassen wieder und wieder darauf
hinzuweisen und darauf hinzuwirken dass
wir weiter konsequent und diszipliniert
sein müssen und je nachhaltiger die
produktionszahl unter 1 geht umso mehr
und nachhaltiger können wir auch wieder
öffentliches soziales wirtschaftliches
leben entfalten das ist ja unser aller
interesse
und um diese situation auch gut
bewältigen zu können brauchen wir vor
allen dingen das sagen uns alle
internationalen erfahrungen eine präzise
nach verfolgung aller infektionsketten
das heißt jeder der neu infiziert ist
muss daraufhin befragt werden mit
welchen kontaktpersonen er oder sie in
kontakt waren die müssen alle
miteinander in quarantäne und dass wir
das präzise hinbekommen das wird nur
gelingen wenn wir den öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienst stärken
dazu sind schon fast abreden zwischen
bund und ländern getroffen wollen worden
nämlich am 25 märz das pro 20.000
einwohner mindestens ein kontakt nach
verfolgungs team aus fünf personen in
einsatz gebracht wird und wir haben
jetzt miteinander besprochen dass durch
das bundesgesundheitsministerium
finanziert 105 mobile teams zur
unterstützung des öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienstes bei kontaktpersonen
nachverfolgung management beschult und
zur unterstützung vor ort eingesetzt
werden können das ist heute auch mit den
ländern besprochen worden
es wird eine meldepflicht geben ab 22
april durch die länder
das gesundheitsämter die diese aufgabe
noch nicht erfüllen können dies den
landes aufsichtsbehörden melden damit
wir abhilfe schaffen können zum beispiel
in brandenburg hilft die bundeswehr bei
solchen kontakt nachverfolgung das sind
ja keine gesundheits spezifischen
kenntnisse sondern sind einfach
telefonketten die man auch setzen muss
wir werden beim rk ii eine service
einheit kontaktstelle kommunale
öffentlicher gesundheitsdienst mit 40
mitarbeitern aufbauen die dann immer für
zehn gesundheitsämter ansprechpartner
sind das mag sich sehr technisch anhören
aber wir wissen aus südkorea aus den
asiatischen ländern die sich mit solchen
pandemien beschäftigt haben oder
epidemien
das ist von entscheidender bedeutung ist
dass wir genau diese infektionsketten
und zwar jeder einzelne gut
nachvollziehen können dann können wir
das virus wirklich eindämmen lockerungen
ohne diese bessere erfassung werden
nicht die erwünschte wirkung entfalten
und wie gesagt ich möchte dass wir
möglichst bald und möglichst erfolgreich
natürlich diesen reproduktions faktor
auch weiter drücken können dankeschön
das war's für heute
frau bundeskanzlerin ist gab die meldung
dass sie im cdu-präsidium heute von
öffnungs diskussions orgien gesprochen
haben finden sie den begriff angemessen
angesichts des wunsches vieler menschen
zu einem normalen leben zurückzukehren
verstehe ich den wunsch das habe ich ja
eben ganz ausführlich gesagt und ich
habe hier schon mehrfach gestanden und
gesagt nichts wäre mir lieber als allen
mitteilen zu können dass wir vorankommen
und wir haben ja heute auch miteinander
die ersten schritte gesehen aber ich
habe gemahnt dass aus dieser ersten
lockerung nicht zu schnell gehandelt
wird und wir dann weil wir uns in
sicherheit wiegen wir in 14 tagen mit
einem ergebnis dastehen was wir alle
nicht miteinander wollen und dass davon
bin ich zutiefst überzeugt denn wir
wissen dass wir herrn chartis neulich
auf dünnem eis
genannt sind wir wissen dass wir bei
einem reproduktions faktor der nur etwas
über 1 liegt wieder in die situation
kommen dass unser gesundheitssystem
überfordert sein könnte und wir müssen
doch beides miteinander zusammenbringen
auf der einen seite nicht unser
gesundheitssystem zu überfordern und
nicht menschen nicht die notwendige
medizinische behandlung geben zu können
und auf der anderen seite natürlich wo
immer das möglich ist auch lockerungen
durchzuführen das ist die aufgabe vor
der wir stehen
und das ist im übrigen auch der beste
weg durch diese schwere schwere pandemie
und deshalb verstehe ich ihn aber
deshalb sage ich auch der beste weg ist
der der jetzt vorsichtig ist und nicht
leichtfertig
frau bundeskanzlerin auch noch mal dazu
sie haben ja jetzt auch noch mal eben
mit sehr eindringlichen worten noch mal
gemahnt
was genau beunruhigt sie eigentlich so
sehr ist das jetzt einfach die tatsache
dass ab heute in vielen regionen leben
wieder geöffnet sind und daher das
risiko wieder steigt oder haben sie auch
das gefühl dass die ganze diskussion
momentan ein bisschen in eine falsche
richtung läuft weiß ich sie werden ja
selbst den eindruck haben wenn sie durch
berlin fahren in den parks in es sind in
der tat ja ziemlich viele leute auch
wieder draußen bei dem schönen wetter
muss man die menschen vielleicht auch
noch mal anders ansprechen
eindringlicher oder wie können sie
praktisch dieses risiko vermitteln ja
ich habe ja den beschluss selbst mit
gefasst dass wir leben bis zu 800
quadratmeter wieder aufmachen das ist ja
eine allgemeine gemeinsamkeit gewesen
diesen beschluss haben wir ihn ja auch
vorgestellt aber ich habe den eindruck
dass seit dem vergangenen mittwoch eine
diskussion in gang gekommen ist die
sozusagen eine sicherheit vielleicht
insinuiert wie sie heute überhaupt noch
nicht da ist und über die wir alle
miteinander nichts aussagen können weil
wir erst in 14 tagen wissen was die
beschlüsse bedeuten und ich habe den
eindruck dass das was wir auch
beschlossen haben am mittwoch nur einer
der nicht im haus stand wohnt mit
anderen aus dem haus stand zusammen
draußen im freien geben sich sonst in
dem eigenen hausstand aufhalten dass
dieses alles dinge sind die vielleicht
ein bisschen in den hintergrund getreten
sind und dass man sie gleich rang ich
wieder hervorholen muss und natürlich
hier weiter wäre zum beispiel das
ladenöffnungsgesetz fassen desto mehr
andere kommen und sagen ja wenn einer
fast alles bekommt warum bekomme ich da
nichts dann verstehe ich natürlich auch
die kirchen die sagen natürlich ist es
ein legitimes interesse auch wieder
gottesdienste zu haben und die aufgabe
von uns allen das gesellschaftliche
leben in veränderter form durch die
pandemie das wird ja noch sehr lange
gehen bis der impfstoff da ist aber in
veränderter form wieder möglich zu
machen bedeutet doch auch dass ich nicht
einen sektor ausgreifen und der bekommt
sozusagen
alle rechte sondern dass ich auch
versuchen die verschiedenen
gesellschaftlichen bereiche immer auch
ein stück weit mitzunehmen und die
berechtigten wünsche der christen
muslime und juden in unserem land denen
ein stück raum einzuräumen
die berechtigten wünsche der eltern zu
sehen und das müssen wir in einem guten
klang hinbekommen ohne die zahl der
kontakte so wachsen zu lassen dass wir
wieder in den phase eines exponentiellen
wachstums kommt und da sag ich mal hab
ich heute in der tat mich mahnend
eingelassen dass wir nachdem wir so viel
erreicht haben schon aber eben nicht am
ende des wegs sind nicht über den berg
sind dass wir das nicht aufs spiel
setzen sondern bin der meinung das wäre
jammerschade wenn wir kommen müssten uns
sagen müssen das muss jetzt leider
rückgängig gemacht werden
frau bundeskanzlerin
welchen grund sehen sie darin dass die
von den ministerpräsidenten jahr
angestoßene debatte über diese lockerung
passiert wird ist das ein
überbietungswettbewerb um im eigenen
land besser dazustehen ist dass der
druck der wirtschaft und befürchten sie
damit jetzt eigentlich
wettbewerbsverzerrungen und eine
unklarheit ob es diese masken pflicht
bundesweit gibt geben wird oder nicht
naja bei den massen sind wir das letzte
mal schon sehr viel weiter gegangen als
sie male davor wir haben jetzt
inzwischen auch mehr masten verfügbar
die situation hat sich verändert und ein
land nach dem anderen sagt ja auch wir
werden im öpnv zumindest also der
abstand gar nicht gewahrt werden kann
haben wir einige länder auch heute
wieder nach gezogen oder auch einzelne
städte
ich glaube dass insgesamt doch der druck
verständlicherweise sehr sehr groß ist
das ist doch klar
sie hören die künstler sie hören die
eltern das ist doch auch verständlich
dass es eine zeit wie wir sie nie erlebt
haben das jetzt nach dem zweiten
weltkrieg
und natürlich überlegt da jeder was kann
ich vielleicht noch verantworten was
nicht aber wir sollten nicht so zu sagen
jetzt es kann auch ein fehler sein dass
man zu schnell voranschreiten das ist
mein meine sorge und ich möchte gerne
dass wir den ausgewogenen weg den wir
geschafft haben
schauen sie bei uns durfte man hat man
nie die parks geschlossen die waren in
österreich geschlossen die sind in
frankreich geschlossen diesen in italien
kann man das nicht machen
bei uns dürfte man immer rausgehen nicht
eine stunde oder 2 und ich möchte dass
wir dieses diesen weg den wir jetzt
miteinander doch auch erfolgreich
gegangen sind dass wir den nicht aufs
spiel setzen das ist mein punkt und und
ich sehe trotzdem die nöte der anderen
auch und da gruppen die natürlich sagen
wenn die einen verkaufen dürfen warum
darf ich noch nicht arbeiten und wir
müssen uns doch immer auch begründen und
wir wissen sicherlich auch diskutieren
habe auch nichts gegen die
gesellschaftliche diskussion darüber
aber ich fühle mich als bundeskanzlerin
auch verpflichtet in diese diskussion
meine haltung mit einzel
und eine dieser haltung zum beispiel ist
das auch die leopoldina die ja durchaus
über lockerungen gesprochen hat und auch
ihre über deren wirkung immer gesagt hat
es muss jede infektionskette
nachvollzogen werden können und ehrlich
gesagt das können wir heute noch nicht
und wenn mir wäre noch wohler wenn wir
das schon könnten als wir müssen auch
diesen zweiten teil nicht nur die
lockerungen sondern eben auch dieses
infektionsketten nachverfolgen ganz ganz
akribisch machen
da kommt es auf jeden einzelnen fall an
bundeskanzlerin der
bundesentwicklungsminister müller hat
die chinesische regierung aufgefordert
informationen bereitzustellen über
eventuelle vorgänge in labors in hahn
war dass in der bundesregierung
abgestimmt
wie sehen sie das nein das war nicht
abgestimmt darüber haben wir nicht
gesprochen innerhalb der bundesregierung
es gibt ja diese diskussion schon seit
geraumer zeit ich glaube dass die
transparenz china einfach die
entstehungsgeschichte dieses virus
deutlich macht umso besser ist das für
uns alle auf der ganzen welt um daraus
lernen zu können aber diese spezifische
diskussion haben wir nicht geführt
frau bundeskanzlerin sie hatten vor
allem die not der menschen angesprochen
der bürger aber auch der unternehmen
oder der gastronom nun sind ja
verschiedene diskussionspunkte im spiel
gerade für die gastronomen absenkung der
mehrwert des mehrwertsteuersatzes oder
die anhebung des kurzarbeitergeldes
geldes wie ist ihre position in diesen
punkten und braucht es vielleicht im
koalitionsausschuss am mittwochabend um
dort den knoten zu durchschlagen danke
beim koalitionsausschuss werden wir
sicherlich über diese fragen sprechen
wir müssen jetzt nur aufpassen dass wenn
ich jede woche eine maßnahme uns
vornehmen und in der nächsten woche
wieder eine andere sondern dass wir noch
mal überlegen wo stehen wir wo sind
probleme das ist weil er kann bei der
gastronomie sein wenn eines tages dort
wieder öffnungen sind im augenblick ist
das ja nicht das zentrale thema das kann
und ist vielleicht beim kurzarbeitergeld
obwohl wir da auch sehr unterschiedliche
gegebenheiten haben wir haben menschen
mit einem sehr geringen einkommen aus
zum beispiel auch im gastronomiebereich
oder im dienstleistungsbereich insgesamt
wir haben aber auch unternehmen die noch
100 prozent aufstocken in den
tarifgebundenen bereichen wir haben die
künstler und wir haben vieles andere
mehr und deshalb denke ich dass wir auf
jeden fall am mittwoch darüber sprechen
werden wo müssen wir uns mit möglichen
handlungsbedarf noch einmal beschäftigen
aber die maßnahmen sind natürlich jetzt
auch erst sehr kurz in kraft und man
muss jetzt aufpassen dass wir nicht in
zu kleinen abständen immer wieder eine
gruppe ins visier nehmen sondern dass
wir da man uns einen gesamtüberblick
verschaffen
frau bundeskanzlerin sie sagen ja immer
südkorea sei beispielhaft mit der
pandemie umgegangen und loben ist ja
auch als vorbild warum gibt es dann
keine allgemeine masken pflicht in
deutschland einzelne länder und städte
gehen voran
haben sie erwähnt aber ihre haltung dazu
ist meiner ansicht nach nicht ganz
deutlich geworden und auch eine zweite
frage wenn sie erlauben
sie sind ja auch von den maßnahmen
betroffen wenn ich wissen dürfte wie
haben sie denn das wochenende verbracht
haben sie sich an die frische luft
getraut waren sie in berlin oder
möglicherweise in der uckermark man
genau meine minuten verbringe sage ihnen
ich habe mich jedenfalls an alle regeln
gehalten die verhängt werden oder die
verhängt worden sind und was die masken
anbelangt ich möchte nicht etwas also
erstens ist das nicht die zuständigkeit
des bundes aber damit will ich mich hier
raus regeln reden sondern wir haben
gesagt bei sachgerechtem umgang mit den
community masken können sie einen
beitrag leisten aber ich betone noch
einmal den sachgerechten umgang also
nicht zu lange hintereinander tragen
immer wieder heiß waschen oder
anderweitig die viren abtöten
wir müssen dann sicherstellen und das
ist heute ganz anders als vor vier
wochen dass wir für jeden bürger den wir
das auferlegen mindestens eine wenn
nicht mehrere solcher masken auch zur
verfügung stellen können und das
bestimmt auch ein stück den zeit schritt
und dann muss man sich überlegen wo ist
es jetzt notwendig wenn ich alleine in
großem abstand zu anderen im park
spazieren gehe weiß ich nicht ob das so
notwendig ist wenn ich aber im
öffentlichen personennahverkehr bin dann
gibt es gute gründe dass auch zu
verlangen wenn genügend masken da sind
frau bundeskanzlerin einen blick nahe
zum donnerstag da haben sie eine eu
schallte es gibt jetzt
kompromissvorschläge im streit wie man
den corona besonders kroner betroffenen
ländern helfen kann dass man das über
das über den eu haushalt macht und eu
anleihen ist das für sie ein gangbarer
weg um zum beispiel italien und spanien
zu helfen
wir haben ja jetzt schon mit dem
instrument des artikel 122 absatz 1b ab
satz zwei war es in dem falle durchaus
ein instrument gefunden wo auch durch
garantien der mitgliedstaaten anleihen
für länder dann weitergegeben werden und
daraus länder zum beispiel das
kurzarbeitergeld finanziert werden kann
solche instrumente kann ich mir auch
weiter vorstellen die ich überhaupt
generell und allgemein sagen möchte dass
deutschland nicht nur solidarisch sein
möchte sondern auch solidarisch sein
wird aber das muss im rahmen der
heutigen verträge sein und es muss
natürlich berücksichtigen dass alle
länder und alle mitgliedstaaten der
europäischen union in diese situation
gekommen sind ohne verschulden das ist
eine pandemie die ist über uns gekommen
das ist nicht das ergebnis von
irgendwelchen mängeln in der
wirtschaftspolitik oder andere anderen
dingen und des weiteren ist meine maxime
immer dass es deutschland auf dauer nur
gut geht wenn es europa gut geht das
heißt es ist nicht nur ein gebot der
solidarität sondern es auch ein gebot
sagen wir des eigennutzes beides
gleichermaßen dass es europa insgesamt
gut geht und so werden wir uns auch
verhalten und deshalb schmerzt es mich
fast dass ich das immer wieder betonen
muss das ist für mich eine
selbstverständlichkeit wir haben jetzt
ein paket von 500 milliarden geschnürt
die finanzminister das muss jetzt
umgesetzt werden
und ich kann mir das sehr gut vorstellen
dass der haushalt natürlich nicht so
aussieht wie wir in diskutiert haben als
das letzte mal über die mittelfristige
finanzielle vorausschau in physischer
anwesenheit in brüssel das getan haben
und das glaube ich gilt für alle dieser
haushalt wird anders aussehen
ich kann mir sehr gut vorstellen dass er
in den ersten jahren nach der pandemie
ganz andere finanzielle möglichkeiten
haben muss aber auch das muss innerhalb
der laufenden verträge seien
man kann über eine neue verträge
diskutieren aber dann braucht man zwei
drei jahre um das lösung zu finden
wir werden schneller antworten auf diese
pandemie brauchen und deutschland wird
sich an solidarischen antworten
beteiligen über das hinaus was wir jetzt
schon mit den 500 milliarden die
dankeschön